the gods and goddesses of Olympus for a
topic that I've rarely discussed on this
channel and if I'm being completely
honest with you I don't really know why
I've put them off for so long so as we
continue our journey into Greek
mythology is the goddess Demeter that we
will be examining today so starting with
her name there are a few ways it can be
pronounced depending on how authentic
you want to sound the English
translation is quite simply Demeter but
as a general rule of thumb if a word has
been translated from Greek into English
and now begins with the letter D the way
it's pronounced in Greek will differ the
D sound is often replaced by th or what
sounds like thee Demeter in Greek is
pronounced that VMedia
with the emphasis placed on the second E
and the me in metre Demeter was of
course one of the original six Olympians
to be born from the tightness Rhea and
then swallowed by Cronus her father once
released him with her father defeated
Demeter would then go on to become quite
a key figure in the lives of the ancient
Greek people as the goddess of the grain
this not only included agriculture and
the harvest but also nourishment and
growth of the earth and humanity the
ancient Greeks had the belief that the
overall fertility of the earth was down
to Demeter and because of this several
cults formed in Demeter's name in order
to honor the goddess and to show their
gratitude but also to ensure that the
earth remained fertile because it did
directly affect their food supply the
cult of Seto or SID though referred to
the goddess as she of the grain because
the ancient Greeks believed that it was
through Demeter they were given food and
grain the second of Demeter's cults that
was known for its annual festival was a
Thesz nefaria which mainly focused on
Demeter and her daughter Persephone it
was fairly common practice for men to be
completely forbidden from attending this
festival and even just seeing or hearing
about the events that took place was
frowned upon and the women of Demeter's
cult kept their secrets quite secret the
first of Love Soft took placed her in
the end of summer close to the harvest
period and it would last for several
days now as to what exactly took place
during this festival we don't really
know but there are some accounts that
suggest that special Peaks were
sacrificed and placed into pits known as
negara the pigs entrails along with
cakes and bread baked in the shapes of
serpents and phalluses would then be
placed on altars dedicated to Demeter
and her daughter so the yearly routine
for a Greek woman who was parted to meet
his cult involved killing some pigs
throwing him in a pit and then Bacon's
and penis cake which I do find quite
amusing because penis shaped cakes are
something that we knew when he
see around bridal parties and birthday
parties unless they've been secretly
worshipping to me to this whole time and
we just never knew about it in that case
we've just uncovered the penis cake
conspiracy or maybe I just like saying
penis cake
I don't really know anyway I digress
enough to talk about cake this festival
is one of the most widely celebrated
across ancient Greece because of how
integral Demeter was to the survival of
the ancient Greek people and the risk of
anger in Demeter was far too great and
we will discuss what exactly the goddess
was capable of a bit later on in the
video
over the years Demeter had numerous
consorts which in turn resulted in
numerous children the most well known of
these being Persephone who was fathered
by Zeus and who I'm sure many of you are
already familiar with one of the lesser
discuss relations was with ESO the son
of Zeus and the nymph Electra when
attending the marriage of Cadmus and
Harmonia Demeter lured him away from the
celebrations and into a field where the
two would enjoy the sunset and roam
around in the field counting sheep and
I'm kiddin they just had sex when they
did eventually return to the
celebrations the back of Demeter's dress
was covered in mud because that is what
happens if you choose to roll around in
a field now this in itself wouldn't have
been much of a problem but it was
spotted by Zeus who would guess what had
happened and who reacted out of anger
and jealousy well maybe it was out of
boredom and pleasure no one really knows
of Zeus because he just does whatever he
wants whenever he pleases regardless of
why he chose to do so he then proceeded
to strike down a source of a single bolt
of lightning Demeter did however have
his twin sons
Pluto's the god of wealth and Filomena's
the god of Agriculture and husbandry the
rasam tells a Demeter they go all the
way back to the Bronze Age around the
same time we have the first accounts of
people speaking Greek these tales would
associate Demeter with Poseidon rather
than Zeus in these somewhat primitive
stories Poseidon was seen as a water
spirit who appeared as a horse that
would pursue Demeter
who appeared as a mayor now for some of
you this story may sound familiar that's
because it is quite similar to the story
of nemesis in Zeus Demeter wanting to
avoid Poseidon transformed herself into
her ancient form which was that of a
mayor but Poseidon then transformed
himself into a stallion in order to mate
with the goddess she would then bore
Poseidon several children despina or
their spinner the goddess of mysteries
it was a central figure of the
Eleusinian mysteries the simplest way to
describe the illusion ian's mysteries is
as the initiation process held annually
for those who wish to join the cult of
Demeter and Persephone
dis B Nord often appear alongside her
mother during these trials as the
mistress whose real name would only be
revealed to those initiated into the
cult of her mother or her very own
Acadian cult Demeter and her daughter
would often be seen as the two great
goddesses of Arcadia
but this daughter was later replaced by
Persephone in the years that followed
the second child of Poseidon and Demeter
was Ariane a swift divine horse with the
gift of speech who appears in a work of
Homer as the horse of king addressed us
of August there is no men that shall
catch the by a burst of speed neither
past the bye nay not enough in pursuit
he were driving godly Ariane the Swift
horse of addresses that was of heavenly
stock these were just some of the meet
his children who were mentioned by more
than just name she was said to have had
no less than nine children of Tripta
Lemus the threefold warrior and several
more for Titan Oceanos having already
discussed some of the metres
lesser-known children I'm sure many of
you are waiting to hear about one in
particular the daughter that she had
with Zeus and the child that she
arguably had the strongest connection
with Persephone for the most part
Persephone seen as the queen of the
underworld but as a young woman she was
the goddess of springtime flowers and
vegetation all things that we can link
back to her mother so it's no real
surprise that they spent most days
together and formed a very close
connection the issue then arose when
Hades fell in love with Persephone and
Demeter would not bless their marriage
because to her Persephone was a beacon
of life and to be surrounded by the dead
in Hades was not a future that she
wished for her daughter it's fairly
difficult to say of any certainty
whether her reaction here was a
manifestation of her feelings towards
her brother Hades or rather her own
personal desire for her daughter to
experience life to its fullest and not
to be condemned to an eternity in the
underworld regardless of the media's
concerns
Zeus had already promised Hades one of
his daughters as a bride and Hades had
indeed chosen Persephone knowing that
Demeter would never win in the allow
Persephone to join Hades in the
underworld
the two brothers hatched a plan which in
most cases ended with Persephone being
abducted when she was separated from her
mother
there are numerous versions of this
story where Hades made his feelings
known to Persephone and she accepted his
proposal when Tomita returned to see her
daughter had disappeared without a trace
or even a sign she was so distraught
that she vowed to search night and day
never to rest for sleep would never
bring back Persephone with aid from the
Galasso karta whose torches lit the
darkness Demeter was able to search
during the night but sadly to no avail
she eventually transformed herself into
an old woman hoping that disguising her
appearance or to make the answers that
she was looking for easier to come by
her in her search for her daughter she
came across the Palace of Salinas the
king of West Attica still in the guise
of an old woman she asked the king for
shelter which he granted on the
condition that she nursed his two sons
Tripta limas and Emma fawn if the search
for her daughter momentarily halted
Demeter was finally able to rest and she
wished to repay the king's kindness by
making both of his sons immortal she
covered them a phone-in ambrosia and
placed him in the flames of the hearth
where the boy's mortal self would burn
away but his mother Queen Metin era
worked in during this ritual only to see
her son engulfed in flames she began to
scream assume in her son was dead and
eventually Demeter pulled the boy from
the flames before the process was
complete demo from remained completely
unharmed but he was still very much
immortal Demeter instead chose to show
her gratitude by teaching trip to Lemus
the secret of Agriculture which he would
then teach to the people of his father's
kingdom and this story was considered to
be one of the earliest explanations as
to how humanity learned to plant grow
and harvest grain Tripta Lemus was seen
by many as Demeter's first priest and
the ambassador to humanity through him
to meet his creation of agriculture
would be taught to the masses soon after
leaving the palace Demeter was told by
her karta that the titan helios had
witnessed the events that took place
when Persephone had gone missing and so
she set out to consult with him where
she learnt of her daughter's abduction
and the roles played by Hades and Zeus
during the search for her daughter
Demeter abandoned her responsibilities
the seasons halted crops flowers and all
things living began to die with fruit
supplies now scarce humanity began to
starve and perish they pray to Zeus in
the hopes that he could save them but he
could do nothing the only things you
could do is plead of Demeter to return
to her post but she refused to do so
unless Persephone was returned to the
land of the living now faced with the
possibility of all life becoming extinct
Zeus had no choice but to bring his
daughter back and so he sent the
messenger of the gods Hermes to retrieve
her Hades agreed that he would return
Persephone but before she left he
convinced the dita pomegranate which
then bound her to his domain
when Hermes returned with the bad news
to meet was furious
she made it known to Zeus that if her
daughter was not returned then she would
make it so all life would cease to exist
and thus they eventually struck an
agreement between them Persephone would
spend a portion of the year in the
underworld of hade
and the rest will be spent on the earth
with her mother this story was off the
news by the ancient Greeks as a way to
explain the different seasons and there
are numerous versions and
interpretations with a duration and the
exact time of year Persephone spent in
the underworld completely different some
like to believe that spring and summer
signified Persephone and her mother
being reunited and the unfruitful winter
signified her return to Hades if there
is one thing that we do learn from this
story its how powerful Demeter truly is
the goddess of the harvest isn't one
that you would associate a great amount
of power with but you would be wrong we
see that Demeter refusing to perform her
duties for a short period of time
results in almost the death of
everything and this does become a threat
used to ensure the return of Persephone
Zeus peed in the position where he's
completely powerless isn't one that we
see too often in Greek mythology but in
this occasion he is truly helpless and
has no other option but to concede to
the demands being made now some of you
may be thinking how does Demeter have
any leverage in his position to begin
with and you can definitely ask the
question why would you scare of humanity
in all things living died and how does
that affect him negatively humanity made
up the vast majority of Zeus's
worshipers they were his children his
wives and he's many affairs Demeter not
only threatened destroy those who adored
and worshipped zeus but also everything
that zeus and his fellow gods had built
and that is why in this scenario he
truly has no choice but to concede so
we've briefly gone over some of the
consorts and children associated of
Demeter along with some of the popular
stories that she appeared in but we've
not really discussed her relationship
with the ancient Greek people in any
real detail Demeter is one of the most
respected Greek deities because of how
dependent the ancient Greeks were on
grain and the harvest the origins of
Demeter's name can be traced back and
translated to roughly mean mother earth
or the Earth Mother and if we look at
Gaia as the earth itself then Demeter's
role is very similar to that of a mother
caring and nourishing for the earth to
ensure that it flourishes if the ancient
Greeks identified several plants with
Demeter
including wheat mint and the poppy which
were all considered to be sacred to her
of the poppy even be in one of her many
symbols there are some accounts were
Demeter is considered to be part of a
triple goddess closely associated to the
story of Persephone subduction the
triple god has consisted of her karta
who assumed the role of the wise old
crone Demeter herself who is the carried
mother and Persephone who represents the
exuberance of youth we can also
interpret the three goddesses as
representing the past present and future
unlike her siblings Damita did not
demand respect nor did she command fear
her many cults and the Greek people
worshiped her out of appreciation and
gratitude for what she provided humanity
her worship for the most part was done
in conjunction with her daughter
now this daughter was originally to
spanner but she was later replaced by
Persephone in the years that followed
and this is very important because it
does highlight some of the meet his best
qualities she was caring and protective
not only to her children but also to the
ancient Greek people and that is why
they held her in such high esteem over
the years humanity faced many hardships
and challenges but Demeter and what she
provided proved to be a constant source
of reliability and consistency and that
is unless you try and take away her
daughter because in that case you'll
probably just die of starvation
if you have enjoyed this video and you
think it's worth alike then that would
be greatly appreciated and if you want
to subscribe and even hit the
notification build and all of that stuff
really helps the channel if there was
anything mentioned that you'd like to
discuss or add to the video then please
feel free to do so in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and penis cakes explained
you